alle leute hier ist wieder eure wahl
wandel heute habe ich mir was ganz
besonderes ausgedacht porträtzeichnen
sich zeichner erst mal vor
dann gibt es wieder meine tipps sind ja
super angekommen das letzte mal danke
dass ihr mein video angeschaut habt
hätte ich echt nicht gerechnet dass sich
das mehr als meine mama oder papa oder
vielleicht ein dankeschön an dieser
stelle
hallo mama hallo papa ich lebe falls sie
das gab mir geht's gut kartoffeln weiß
immer noch nicht ganz immer wie man
kocht auch dieses mal brauchen wir ein
blatt papier
wer ist bleistifte radici und die kunst
des zeichnens
so leute ich hab jetzt schon mal die
augen und die nase gemalt was ich euch
jetzt zeigen möchte wie man den mund mal
nimmt jetzt einfach mal euren bleistift
dann nehme ich den b2b und dann werde
ich euch jetzt mal zeigen wie die mund
zeichen technik funktioniert so das
war's jetzt eigentlich auch schon so
könnt ihr das eigentlich lassen
jetzt habe ich wieder einen ganz tollen
tipp für euch und dazu braucht ihr den
230 retriever lippenstift und da werden
wir jetzt einfach mal die lippen
das dauert noch ein bisschen länger
ok
nicht viel auftragen denn sonst könnte
es vielleicht unnatürlich aus und das
wollen wir ja ganz natürlich schnell
durch den schweiz bei instagram
hochladen
neben vier mal
ja das ist immer ein geiler filter
heftig deftig of sydney heftig jolo
hashtag #tatort
und dann poste das und hoffe dass ganz
vieles licon weil du like for like us
schreibst und das ist eigentlich totaler
schwachsinn bei kann auch dieses scheiß
like-for-like klingt also mit jemand
niemand irgendwie dir like dafür geben
für diese scheiße die du damals aber
egal wir postens trotzdem und fertig das
wars
ich hoffe euch jetzt gefallen wenn nicht
dann sagt mir was besser machen kann
wenn doch dann gibt mir doch einen
daumen hoch schreibt auch in die
kommentare
sonst würde ich sagen nächste woche